In Halloween Ends, we see a Laurie Strode who
is trying to find some normalcy in her life.
She needs to overcome her past by celebrating
Halloween like a normal person, rather than going
to war with Michael Myers. To do this, we see her
carve a pumpkin, a holiday activity she took part
in when we first met her in 1978. Back then it was
her, Tommy and Lindsey, and this time she’s with
Allyson and Lindsey. Later on we get a look at
the finished product, and it looks just like the
one she carved all those years ago. I guess her
style hasn’t changed much over the last 44 years.
We also see this in her attire. In the original
film, she had this long brim hat in her room,
which she held onto until 2018, where it would
have been destroyed in the fire. Ironically,
when she burns her pie in Halloween Ends, you
can spot a replacement hat near the front door.
Another trait from Laurie’s past
that persevered is the way she
twirls her hair when she thinks
about her crush. In the original,
she did this while discussing the target
of her high school affection, Ben Tramer,
and now, 44 years later, she reacts similarly when
running into Frank Hawkins at the supermarket.
Maybe you didn’t notice those details when
you first watched the movie, so in this video
I’m gonna go over everything you might have
missed in Halloween Ends, from tiny details in
newspapers to the broader meaning of the entire
film. Stick around to the end of this video.
This video is brought to
you by Established Titles.
(metal music)
Welcome to Things You Missed. We once again
find ourselves at the end of the line here
on the Halloween Express. I’m glad to see one of
these timelines actually have a definitive ending
for once. You could argue that Rob Zombie’s
timeline was definitive, but Halloween Ends
leaves little to the imagination. No matter what
you think about this movie, you have to give the
filmmaker David Gordon Green and writer Danny
McBride credit for finishing what they started.
Every good story has a beginning, middle and end,
even when it does include a timeless character
like Michael Myers. This story has come to an end,
but like every great legend, it can alway
be reimagined for future generations.
While the story may have come to an end,
there are still many more Things You might
have Missed to slash our way though,
so let’s slide in to our next one.
(50s rock)
The opening song of the movie, “Midnight
Monsters Hop” has lyrics that describe
a concert with many classic Halloween
monsters like Dracula, The Invisible Man,
Frankenstein and the Mummy, who started as pop
culture icons, like Michael Myers, but are now
eternal urban legends. These are classic Universal
monsters, and this trilogy of Halloween films was
made by Universal’s Blumhouse, so it’s almost as
if Michael Myers is following in their footsteps.
The opening titles are done in the same
style as the titles from Halloween III:
Season of the Witch, the black sheep of the
franchise. This made me realize that there’s
a pattern. Halloween (2018) was the first
Blumhouse Halloween, and it mimics the titles
from Halloween 1. Halloween Kills was the second
Blumhouse Halloween and its titles resemble Rick’s
Halloween 2. Ends is the third of the Blumhouse
trilogy, so it took the style of Halloween III.
The opening scene shows our new character Corey
babysitting for this kid named Jeremy. As the
parents are about to leave, I noticed the mom
holding a small drone. It reminded me of that
scene from Halloween Kills, where Michael
destroys Sonda’s drone, before attacking
her and her husband. But I don’t think this
drone is a callback, because shortly after,
we see that Jeremy prefers playing with paper
airplanes. He has access to the newest technology,
but still chooses the old classic. We
also see Laurie playing with a paper
plane when she confronts Corey later on. It seems
symbolic for a movie with two main antagonists,
the old classic, Michael Myers, and the
newcomer, Corey Cunningham. Corey just
ends up modeling himself after Michael,
so once again, the original can’t be beat.
– It’s Halloween. We’re gonna
have a good time tonight.
– Thank God he didn’t say everyone’s entitled
to one good scare. Corey and Jeremy end up
watching John Carpenter’s The Thing, which
is a remake of The Thing From Another World,
which Laurie and Tommy watched in the original.
It’s significant that they chose
John Carpenter’s The Thing because
as you may know, John Carpenter
directed the original Halloween,
and Halloween Ends honors more of
his filmography. In particular,
Ends is more of a remake of John Carpenter’s 1983
film Christine than it is a Halloween sequel.
In Halloween Ends, we follow a character named
Corey Cunningham, who is an obvious homage to
Christine’s main character, Arnie Cunningham.
Spoilers for Christine until the end of this
chapter. Arnie starts off as kind of a loser until
he buys this old car named Christine and decides
to fix it up. As he does so, he becomes cooler
and starts to stand up for himself against his
bullies and his overly strict parents. The
car is actually a supernatural entity with
the ability to repair herself and go after
Arnie’s enemies on her own. Owning this car
changes his personality and grows his ego, but
it goes too far, and Arnie becomes a villain,
willing to attack those who care about him
when they show concern about the evil car.
In Halloween Ends, Corey starts as an outcast
because of his babysitting accident. Like Arnie,
he gets his glasses broken by high school bullies,
and his life is dominated by his strict mother,
but his luck starts to change when he
receives this motorcycle from his step dad,
with the promise that he can fix it up. Corey
works at Prevo Auto, which looks like a smaller
version of Darnell’s Garage where Arnie fixes up
Christine. I found it interesting that Prevo Auto
was established in 1963, the same year Michael
seemingly became evil and killed his older sister.
It’s like there’s this parallel between Michael
and the junkyard, which is appropriate because
Corey’s motorcycle is not the “Christine” of this
movie. Michael Myers is Christine. Let me explain.
Corey is always said to be a good kid who had a
bad break. Even the father of the boy he killed
admits that Jeremy’s death was an accident, but
something else later seemed to send Corey down a
dark path. It is true that this happens right
after he gets the motorcycle, but it’s around
this same time that he first encounters Michael
Myers. Like Christine, Michael Myers is in a sad
state when we first encounter him, and Corey, like
Arnie, develops a strange fascination with him.
Christine seems to have Arnie under some kind
of trance as soon as he lays eyes on her,
and Halloween Ends features this moment where
Corey and Michael first make eye contact and
something non-verbal seems to be passed between
them. Christine seems to regain her power after
Arnie spends countless hours fixing her up in the
garage, and in Michael’s case, he seems to regain
power after Corey brings him a new victim.
The way Christine puts herself back together
even kind of resembles the way that Michael
visually regains his mojo after taking a life.
In each film, the Cunningham character gains
more confidence and swagger after their first
encounter with the supernatural.
They both ditch their glasses,
because not wearing glasses instantly
makes you more attractive in a movie.
– Hey man, no glasses. You’re looking good.
– Arnie Cunningham starts dating the most coveted
girl in the school, and Christine tries to kill
her by locking her in the cabin when she starts
choking. Corey Cunningham meets and begins to date
Allyson, who is similarly an enemy of Michael.
Arnie stops listening to his mother and stops
respecting his parents, and Corey does the same.
Finally, Christine is totalled by bullies, so
after getting fixed, she goes after them and hunts
them down. Each time, we see the bright headlights
blasting them before Christine chases them down
and kills them. In Halloween, the bullies try
to ruin Corey’s motorcycle, and he confronts them
by targeting them in the bright lights of the tow
truck before running them down. It's definitely
paying tribute to that iconic Christine shot.
In the end, Arnie’s best friend and ex-girlfriend
battle and defeat Christine in the auto garage,
where she’s compacted and dumped in the junkyard,
but they are unable to save Arnie. While
in Halloween Ends, Laurie and Allyson also
defeat Michael and bring him to the junkyard to
be destroyed, but they are unable to save Corey.
There’s also a cameo in this movie from Diana
Prince, who is known in the horror community as
co-host of The Last Drive-In. One of Chrstine’s
iconic scenes takes place at a drive-in movie.
There was talk earlier this year of
Christine getting its own Blumhouse remake,
which Stephen King, the author of the novel, was
not thrilled about, so I’m hoping Halloween Ends
is instead of that, because I think I prefer
this weird amalgamation of two John Carpenter
movies to a remake of a movie that still holds
up, and doesn’t really need to be remade. Plus,
Stephen King liked it -- seriously
Blumhouse, quit while you’re ahead.
After meeting Corey, we move on to Laurie, who
has a collection of newspapers pinned to her wall,
which contain a few Things You might have Missed.
(impact)
Established Titles is a fun and novel
way to preserve the natural woodlands of
Scotland while helping global reforestation
efforts. The project is based on a historic
Scottish custom where landowners are referred
to as Lairds -- or Lords & Ladies in English.
You can buy a title pack, ranging from as much
as 10 sq ft to as little as 1 sq ft of land,
and with each order, they will plant a tree
(your tree) and work with global charities
One Tree Planted and Trees for the Future
to support global reforestation efforts,
which is what we need, because the
Earth is really screwed right now.
You'll receive a title with a unique plot
number on a private estate in Eddleston,
Scotland and an official certificate with a crest.
But the best part is I have made arrangements with
Established Titles , so that the first 200 people
to purchase a title with my link will be placed
effectively next to my plot. Meaning that you can
help CZsWorld become a real physical place. And
considering it will be all trees and no cars,
it will be the greatest kingdom of all time.
You could officially include the
title Lord or Lady on your Credit
Card/Plane Tickets/Dating profiles.
It makes an amazing last minute
gift. Established Titles is actually
running a massive early Black Friday
Sale right now, plus if you use the code
CZSWORLD you get an additional 10% off. Go to
EstablishedTitles.com/CZSWORLD to get your
gifts now and help support the channel.”
(mysterious music)
One thing Halloween Ends does really well
is foreshadowing, which makes it a joy to
watch for your second and third viewing. There
are many covert clues about Corey’s transition
to evil and alignment with Michael Myers.
In my Michael Myers Horror History episode,
I talked all about how Michael seems to be stuck
in a childlike mindset because of his trauma at
six years old. Corey seems to have that same
mindset, which can be seen in his beverage of
choice. In the opening he’s confronted with a
choice between chocolate milk and beer and he
goes with chocolate milk. Then again at the gas
station, he chooses milk, and refuses to buy
beer for the kids pressuring him in the parking
lot. Beer is obviously an adult beverage, you
have to be 21 to drink it in the US; while milk
is considered beneficial for growing children,
but the lactase enzyme responsible for digesting
it goes away in most adults. I also noticed that
Corey’s mom drinks milk with her spaghetti,
and she definitely has some weird issues.
Another example of foreshadowing can be seen in
Corey’s actual shadow as he heads up the stairs.
It looks like the silhouette of Michael
Myers, which we saw before in Halloween 6.
As I mentioned, Corey is a mechanic, and
we see him in his work uniform early on,
which happens to be the same costume that Michael
Myers wears. He’s also seen using the blow torch,
which he would later weaponize against the leader
of the bullies, Terry, in a pretty awesome kill.
When Corey and Allyson hang out on the rooftop of
the radio station, he claims he’s not interested
in immortality, and drops down to the ground,
falling on his back. He appears to be hurt,
then sits up in the same fashion that Michael
always sits up after a recharge period.
Corey’s death, or at least his apparent
death, is also foreshadowed during the
dance party scene. He’s laying on the
dance floor for some reason and Allyson
runs her hands along his face and neck.
At the end, when Allyson comes home to
discover Corey’s self-inflicted injury,
she finds herself in the same position.
Outside of hints about Corey, there are
also other aspects of the movie that are
set up. The recap at the beginning uses a
shot from the original Halloween of Laurie
attacking Michael with her knitting needle.
Most of us have seen the original Halloween,
but it's a nice touch to include that for
those who haven’t, because it foreshadows
the moment later in Halloween Ends.
We even see that she still knits,
so it makes more sense when she finds the needle
and uses it as a weapon in the final battle.
There are many aspects of the final
showdown that are set up earlier on,
like the scene where Laurie burns her pumpkin
pie. This shows us the location of the fire
extinguisher, so it’s more satisfying when she
gets it and uses it in the finale. Similarly,
there’s a scene where Allyson leaves her
meal in the microwave for too long and it
explodes. Laurie later does this on purpose
as a loud noise that can distract Michael.
(food pops)
Then, when Laurie tries to warn her granddaughter
about Corey, she uses the following words:
– I’m not gonna let this happen
to you, you have to believe me.
– …which are the first words out of Allyson’s mouth
when she comes back to save her grandmother.
– I’m not gonna let this happen to you.
– And the last thing I’m going to point out as
far as foreshadowing, is how they foreshadowed
Michael’s death. One of the first things we ever
see at the junkyard is that industrial shredder,
it’s very brief, but it’s a nice
setup. It’s shown again later on,
but my favorite might be the
butcher at the grocery store.
– Three pound ground chuck. Right here on top.
– Is that a little clue that Michael is going
to eventually become “ground beef” himself?
The procession scene right before Michael’s
body is destroyed is a great way to wrap up
the trilogy, because it allows up to see
many of the characters who made it all
the way through, like Sheriff Barker,
the graveyard caretaker Sondra Larsen,
and the snarky kid Julilan Morrisey. Each
of these characters appeared in all three
movies and survived to the end. We even
see WCZD make one last appearance. Nice.
Let’s move on to the easter eggs. Some Halloween
fans may remember the Halloween novelizations.
These books were not canon, but gave fans a
little bit more detail about their favorite
Halloween stories, characters and lore.
The novelization of the original Halloween
has details about what became of Judith and
Michael’s parents after losing their kids,
where they are given names for the first time:
Donald Myers and Edith Myers. These names are
referenced in Halloween Ends, in an article pinned
to Laurie Strode’s wall titled “6 Year Old Kills
Teen Sister in Halloween Tragedy”. You can see
their names from the novelization are now canon.
There’s also an Obituaries section
revealing the name of Lynda’s mother:
Marlyn Van Der Klok. This is also
a name taken from the novelization.
Then again, you might not want to trust the
newspapers. This article titled “Myers Manhunt
Underway” states that Michael had 27 victims
in 2018. It’s not entirely clear who lived and
who died, but if you tally up the victims
from Halloween (2018) and Halloween Kills,
you would get a number somewhere in the fifties. I
like to think this article was written before all
the bodies had been discovered, but there’s
no excuse you can make for this next part,
where it says in 1978, Michael killed
5 teenagers with Laurie Strode being
the only sole survivor. This is just not
true. Michael killed 3 teenagers that year,
and Laurie was one of four survivors,
alongside Tommy, Lindsey, and Dr. Loomis.
There’s one more potential error here,
where it says Michael was last seen at
45 Lampkin Lane in Haddonfield.
In my Halloween Kills episode,
I talked about how the address of the Myers
house is 709 Lampkin Lane, with 45 Lampkin
Lane being a mistake made in Rick’s Halloween
II, which is not a part of this timeline. It
is possible though, that there’s a neighbor
who actually does live at 45 Lampkin Lane,
who was the last one to spot Michael. Maybe
that’s what the article is talking about.
As long as we’re taking a closer look at
these articles, let’s look at this one:
“Night Blade Landmark Destroyed.” Night
Blade was a working title for Halloween
(2018) during the early stages of production
and the film was made under the company name:
Night Blade Holdings LLC. Kills
followed suit with the company
name being Night Blade 2 Holdings, and
Ends was made by Night Blade 3 Holdings.
But this article was not the only instance
of the behind-the-scenes content being in
the scenes themselves. This hobo
is a cameo by Christopher Nelson,
the special makeup effects designer
for the trilogy. You may remember I
pointed out his other cameo in Halloween
(2018), where he played a police officer.
Debra Hill, who produced on the original three
Halloween movies, is sadly no longer around to
make a cameo appearance, but there is a nurse
character named Deb who seems to be a tribute
to her. During the production of the original
Halloween, she was dating John Carpenter,
and the character Deb is secretly dating
the man calling the shots at the clinic,
Dr. Mathis. Of course, Deb’s death is a direct
retread of a famous death from the original movie.
Throughout Halloween Ends, Laurie can be seen
writing a book in order to help her cope with the
horrible events she has endured. This is almost
certainly a nod to her fellow final girl Sidney
Prescott, who has a similar coping strategy in
Scre4m. Yes, that is the correct pronunciation
based on the spelling, Scre-4-m. The relationship
between Halloween and Scream began in 1996,
in the original Scream, where Halloween was shown
to guests at a party. In 1998, Halloween H20
showed Scream 2 on a dorm room TV. Then in 2000,
Scream 3 has a scene where Sidney’s mother says
she’ll protect her from The Boogeyman, which is
a name that is interchangeable with Michael Myers
in the Halloween franchise. In Scre4m, Sidney is
introduced as the ultimate scream queen beyond
Jamie Lee Curtis, the actress who plays Laurie,
among a variety of other references, so I believe
Laurie’s transformation into a self-help
author is a reference to the fourth Scream.
Her book is titled Stalkers, Saviors and Samhain…
– [Loomis and Zac] Sam Hain.
– [Zac] Samhain is the Gaelic festival marking the
end of the harvest season in Celtic Ireland,
which was a big part of the lore in Halloween 2,
3 and 6. You can watch my episodes on each
of those movies if you want to know more,
but the appearance here on Laurie’s book title is
an easter egg waiting to be noticed by fans of the
originals. There’s another reference to Celtic
Folklore in the song that the homeless man sings
after Corey is thrown off the overpass. You’ve
gotta listen pretty carefully to pick up on it.
– ♪ There's a hole in the boat ♪
♪ And it won't
stay afloat ♪
♪ Oilliphéist in the sea ♪
– If you couldn’t hear that, he says: There's a hole
in the boat. And it won't stay afloat. Oilliphéist
in the sea. This song is called “Oilliphéist,
Fear Thee”. The Oilliphéist is a mythological sea
serpent creature originating in Irish Mythology.
The rest of his song may also be significant.
– ♪ Nail my hands to the door ♪
♪ And my knees to the floor ♪
– At the end of the movie, Michael’s hands
are nailed down with knives and his knees
are trapped down by the refrigerator,
so this line might be connected to that.
But there are still a ton more easter eggs
referencing other films in the franchise,
and I’m gonna talk about how Halloween Ends has
a message about COVID-19 and what the director
meant when he said that Haddonfield is going to
be dealing with the pandemic in Halloween Ends.
(impact)
(mysterious music)
There’s a four year gap in between
the end of Halloween Kills and the
main events of Halloween Ends,
during which Allyson graduates,
gets a job and starts dating a police officer
named Doug Mulaney. This character is most
likely a descendent of the Mulaneys
from the flashback in Halloween Kills.
– That’s what you
get when you **** with the Mulaneys.
– Looks like their family motto
got passed down as well.
– Hey! You don’t **** with Doug Mulaney!
– I gotta admit, I spent way too long
trying to figure out who the Mulaneys
were supposed to be in Kills, and did
not consider it might be a set up for the
next movie. Another connection to Kills
can be seen right here in the graffiti,
which reads “love lives today”, the same text
seen on the donation box back at Mick’s Bar,
which helped inspire everybody’s
favorite line from that middle chapter.
– [Tommy] Love lives today.
– [Marion] But evil dies tonight.
–  [Zac] Next to the “love lives today” graffiti is just
the word “KILLS” incase we forgot the name of
the previous title, and there’s also some
artwork of Michael Myers, which might be of
note because the police procession goes down this
same street before Michael’s execution at the end.
And speaking of the ending, it also has a
couple of Halloween Kills references. After
pinning Michael to the kitchen island, Laurie
shows him his own reflection in the knife,
probably to test Deputy Hawkins’s
theory from the last movie.
– [Hawkins] Maybe he wasn’t looking out. Maybe
he was looking in. At his reflection. At himself.
– And when Michael gets the upper hand she yells “do
it!” in a way that almost looks like
she’s encouraging him to kill her.
– Do it. Do it!
– Of course, she’s really talking to Allyson, is
standing behind Michael and comes to rescue her.
This mirrors the scene in Kills where Allyson
is at Michael’s mercy and yells “do it!”,
but she’s really talking to her mother who
is standing at the door with a pitchfork.
I find it interesting that in order to stop
Michael, Laurie pins him down to the kitchen
island, because in Halloween (2018) she
had set up a much more elaborate trap
for him under her kitchen island, but the
simpler trap ends up being more effective.
Halloween (2018) also shares another
similar line with Ends. At one point,
Corey comes over to visit Allyson late at
night, and he’s extremely flustered. She
tries to calm him down by saying “look
at me”, the same tactic her mother once
used to try to calm down Laurie during her
panic attack at the honors society dinner.
– [Allyson] Look at me.
– [Karen] Mom, look at me.
– Another (2018) connection is visible
when Allyson pulls up to the restaurant
she’s meeting Corey at. The sign out front
advertises Bahn Mi sandwiches, the same type
of sandwich that the cop stationed outside of
Laurie’s house was raving out four years prior.
– A bahn mi sandwich. A bahn mi is essentially
just a Vietnamese version of a French baguette.
– Outside of the 40 year trilogy,
there are still plenty of other
Halloween easter eggs to uncover. I’ll
start with Halloween Resurrection,
and we can work our way backwards. When we
first see Michael’s new home in the sewers,
there’s an insert shot of the rats, which
brings to mind Michael’s lair in Resurrection,
where he lived underneath the house
and fed on rats for sustenance.
In Halloween H20, there was a tense scene where
the character Charlie drops a corkscrew into the
garbage disposal, and Michael sneaks
up on him as he’s reaching in for it,
making it seem as if the boogeyman is going
to flip the switch to grind up Charlie’s
hand. That doesn’t end up happening, but when
Michael tries to force Laurie’s hand into the
garbage disposal in Halloween Ends,
it’s clearly an homage to that scene.
There’s also a part where Laurie holds
onto Michael’s hand after trapping him,
which reminded me a lot of the ending
of H20, where the masked man is trapped
under a van and reaches out to Laurie,
where they briefly touch fingertips.
This movie also features a radio host
getting massacred during a broadcast,
which we saw with Barry Simms in Halloween 6;
a retaliation from an angry driver of a black
convertible that got scratched, which we saw with
Mikey in Halloween 5; an adult giving a teenager
a loaded rifle and telling him to stay put, which
we saw with Sheriff Meeker and Brady in Halloween
4 and a tow-truck being stolen for a murderous
rampage, as we saw Michael do in Halloween 4.
As always, we get a ton of connections to
the immortal classic, the 1978 original
Halloween. It starts when Laurie is
talking to Hawkins in the supermarket,
where you can hear the grocery store cover of
“[Don’t Fear] The Reaper” by Blue Öyster Cult.
[muzak version of "(Don't Fear) The Reaper"]
They must have watched my CHUCKY season 1 video,
where I ranted about how I don’t dislike the
song, but it’s way overused in movies and TV,
because they proceeded to put it twice in this
movie, it also plays over the end credits.
That evening when Allyson and Corey go to
the dance party, Corey bumps into this man,
played by Nick Castle, the actor under the Michael
Myers mask in the original, and also parts of 2018
and Kills. This easter egg is actually a two
parter, because he opens his jacket and asks…
– See anything you like?
– …which is the same line Lynda had in the original
movie when flashing her tits to her boyfriend.
– See anything you like?
Corey goes off on his own, where
he’s jumped by the gang of bullies,
and tossed from the overpass. You can
see Michael Myers in the background
for just a moment, before we pan
down to see that Corey is alive.
Laurie first sees Corey’s behavior start to change
when she notices him peering out from behind the
bush in the front yard. This isn’t really
a Thing You Missed, because the shot in the
original is so iconic, but people will complain
if I don’t mention it. A better one to bring up
would be that night, when Laurie comes home to
see Allyson and Corey heading up to the bedroom
through the front window. In the original, it was
the young Michael Myers who caught a glimpse of
his sister leading her boyfriend upstairs.
This is a continuation of the trend that
I talked about when covering Halloween (2018)
and Halloween Kills, where we are increasingly
seeing the roles reversed between Laurie and
Michael, to where she is becoming the hunter.
Another detail I discussed in my (2018) video
was Allyson’s outfit starting to look like the
wardrobe that Laurie wore in the original, and
we see that again here in the radio tower scene,
where she’s wearing that very familiar blue
button up and jeans. We also see Laurie wearing
pretty much the same thing in the finale.
She first knows that Michael is back when
she notices the open back door, which probably
reminded her of the window he came in through
in ‘78. As she did back then, she hides in a
closet, where she formulates a plan of attack.
The very ending shows an array of still
shots all around Laurie’s house. It’s
just like the ending of the original Halloween,
but this time with no ominous breathing sounds.
I’ve already brought up a few details you might
have missed from the Halloween Ends’s soundtrack,
so here are a couple more. The second song we
hear at the dance party is “Halloween” by Dead
Kennedys, whose lyrics mention a character
who dressed up like a clown for Halloween.
Maybe this is a coincidence, but Michael’s first
costume in the first movie was a clown costume,
and there have been many clown costume
appearances in other Halloween movies.
There are a couple other songs that reflect ideas
expressed in the movie, like when Dr. Mathis gets
home and puts on the song “Tell Me With Your Eyes”
by Rob Galbraith. Eyes are often depicted in this
movie to be indicators of good or evil. Laurie
says she can see Michael in Corey’s eyes. Roger,
the father of the boy who got killed, also
says that when he looked into Corey’s eyes,
he could tell he was down a dark
path. When Corey first meets Michael,
they make eye contact, and something seems
to be passed between, during which we see a
montage that includes a bunch of extreme
close ups of Corey and Michael’s eyes.
Another more overt music choice
is “Burn it Down” by Boy Harsher,
which we hear when Corey and Allyson are
night riding on the motorcycle. This is a
reference to the conversation they had about
their desires to get away from Haddonfield.
– [Allyson] After my mom and dad were
killed I just wanted to burn it all
to the ground and get away from Haddonfield.
– They bring up this phrase a
few more times throughout the
rest of the runtime whenever they
are talking about skipping town,
and this motorcycle scene takes place right before
Corey finally convinces her to head out with him.
But what is the deal with that piano melody that
characters keep playing over and over throughout
the film? To answer that, we’ll have to look
back many years to one legendary composer.
(impact)
(dark music)
We first hear Mr. Allen perform “Toccata and Fugue
in D Minor” by Johann Sebastian Bach in
the opening sequence on Halloween night.
(piano music)
This music choice makes sense, because
this song is most commonly associated
with the classic vampire film, Nosferatu.
Which, if you watch Things You Missed,
you already know is where Michael Myers got
his creepy sit up move from. Remember how
I talked about Corey’s shadow on the
staircase looking like Michael Myers?
That also comes from Nosferatu, which
helped inspire many films to this day.
We hear these iconic notes
repeated throughout Halloween Ends,
when Allyson first enters
the abandoned Allen house…
(piano keys)
…when Corey lets Laurie
Strode slip away…
(piano keys)
and non-diegetically when Michael
comes across Laurie’s new house.
(piano notes)
If you were following updates throughout
the production of Halloween Ends, you may
remember David Gordon-Green talking about
how the time jump in between Halloween Kills
and Ends meant that Halloween Ends would
take place during the COVID-19 pandemic.
In an October 2021 interview with Uproxx, he
stated: “Not only do they have their immediate
world affected by that trauma, having time to
process that trauma -- and that's a specific
and immediate traumatic event in the community of
Haddonfield -- but then they also had a worldwide
pandemic and peculiar politics and another million
things that turned their world upside down.”
This statement made it seem like the movie
was actually going to acknowledge COVID-19,
and to be fair, it does acknowledge it.
Despite the virus breaking out in late 2019,
it didn’t begin to affect life in the United
States until 2020. The opening with Corey and
Jeremy took place in October 2019, and we see a
montage of anguish during subsequent Halloweens.
As a side note, this montage contains a really
dark detail. We see the mother of Oscar Berlucci,
one of the victims in 2018, hanging in a devil
costume, the same outfit her son died in,
almost as if to suggest that she was overcome
with grief and decided she could not go on.
But we also see this crime scene in a Jeep, where
the coroner and crime scene photographer are both
wearing masks, suggesting that this probably
happened in October of 2020. But this is the
only evidence in the movie that the pandemic
began. So what did Gordon-Green mean when he
said that the people of Haddonfield had their
world turned upside down by a worldwide pandemic?
I don’t believe he ever meant that COVID would
be at the forefront of the story, but rather,
it seems to be a big part of the subtext.
Laurie’s whole character arc in this movie
is about learning to move on from a traumatic
event. She had to deal with 50-some people,
including her own daughter, getting killed
after she tried to warn everybody about the
threat that was Michael Myers, and nobody
listened. It sounds a lot like the countless
healthcare professionals who tried to sound
the alarm about COVID-19. Nobody listened,
6.5 million people were killed,
and that number is still rising.
Throughout my Halloween Things You Missed
series, I’ve talked about how many Halloween
films reflect the culture of the time period
they were made in. Halloween Ends is no
different. There’s never been a more impactful
event in our lifetimes, and in this movie,
Michael Myers serves as a stand-in instigator for
the collective grief we’ve all been dealing with.
In fact, there are many instances where Michael
is compared to a virus. There are constant
worries about being “infected” and his evil is
literally referred to as being “contagious.”
– [Laurie] The suffering Michael
caused became an infection, passing onto people who never even crossed his path.
– [Corey] It’s contagious, right?
– [Laurie] The other kind of evil
lives inside us. Like a sickness, or an infection.
– We even see characters trying to spin ridiculous
narratives, like the idea that Michael was an
innocent mental patient that Laurie pushed too
far, causing him to snap. By the time of this
movie, everyone seems desperate to blame
something for hurt that Michael caused.
Did it come from a bat? Was it leaked from
a lab? Does it really matter at this point?
Laurie is our protagonist, and she is trying
to learn to deal with the consequences of
Michael Myers. It’s all about this self
promise of hers, she’s trying not to let
fear rule her life anymore. She still has
some safety precautions, as one should,
but for the first time, we see her trying to get
back to normal, putting up Halloween decorations,
carving pumpkins, and not spending
all of her time preparing to fight.
She does all of this, despite it being generally
accepted that Michael is still out there,
and at times, we see her panic and
revert back to the Laurie we saw
in 2018. Her journey in this movie
is trying to fully overcome that.
That’s why I find the ambiguous ending
regarding the fate of Corey Cunningham to
be kind of interesting. Near the end of the
movie, we see that Corey has the ability to
recover from would-be fatal injuries, like
Michael does, and we never see what happens
to Corey. There are many scenes that imply
that evil is part of a continuous cycle. Even
if you find a way to defeat Michael Myers,
there is always a new evil on the horizon,
whether it’s Corey, or one of the other
deplorable characters in Haddonfield.
Right from the get go, the opening credits
this time show us a series of jack o’lanterns
being born out of other jack o’lanterns,
representing the cycle of evil being reborn.
In one scene, Lindsey does a
tarot card reading for Allyson.
– [Allyson] Oh no, I got the death card.
– No, that’s not bad in tarot. No,
that just means a major phase is
ending an a new one is about to begin.
– It seems to be talking about Allyson
starting a new relationship with Corey,
but in the grand context of the
movie, it’s talking about one
phase of evil ending with Michael,
and a new one beginning in Corey.
A similar theme is expressed in Laurie’s writing.
– I'm hopeful, with perspective,
that my experience will help others heal.
You have to ask yourself, "Am I in control,
"or do the elements control me?” Life
or death. Suicide or cherry blossoms?
– [Zac] Cherry blossoms in Japanese culture are the
symbolic flower of the spring, a time of renewal,
and the fleeting nature of life. We can literally
see the cycle repeating itself in the movie. The
old Myers house is demolished, but there just
ends up being a new horror house in Haddonfield,
when the Allen house is abandoned after
Jeremy’s untimely death. But I think,
whether we are talking about COVID or Michael
Myers, the end of Laurie’s memoir puts it best.
– I’ve said goodbye to my boogeyman. But the
truth is, evil doesn’t die. It changes shape.
– And with that, I have analyzed
everything you might have
missed in the Halloween franchise.
Except for the Rob Zombie duology,
which I skipped over. I think Jimmy Champane
and I will cover those next Halloween.
The playlist on the left is my full collection of
episodes on the Halloween franchise, and if you
love horror, I cover all kinds of horror on this
channel. Make sure you subscribe to CZsWorld, ring
the deathbell for notifications and I will see
you in the next one. Assuming, we both survive.
(spooky dance music)